oh hey salutations
hi we duck hopefully every time we do
this we improve just a little bit more
and our backgrounds get nicer and nicer
you're still a giant Bob and this is my
washing machine yep
for those new who might be news is
resident Knievel Mary Ann I've been
playing through every single one of the
resin Evil games well most of them are
bonuses no this is our 11th yeah we're
doing all right
yeah 11th cuz yeah we did zero code
Veronica revelations yep it's fun yeah
we've had a really good time I've
already done game came out this is 11
yeah this game came out last weekend so
I'm sure a lot of people have beaten it
since unless they're playing along with
us I know there are a few people are
playing along with us yeah I'm gonna
show you some fanart and then we're
gonna get started okay this one's pretty
good this was from Twitter so he's as
far as I understand like I think like a
year ago he started drawing like or
starting and learning to draw and has
been kind of updating us as we've been
doing the show so we're like watching
someone's art progress mm-hmm there's so
much there's so much you can always draw
about Resident Evil yeah oh yeah see the
spades and the diamonds all right I'm
gonna get you never guess you'd have fun
not not on this show you've an earned it
thank you well for the fan art Jaime
alright so getting getting a little back
into it here I think I got a key
I had a decent episode I didn't die
and I don't even think I got attacked by
his aam but I did go through hella
bullets yeah you need got the grenade
launcher yes I have a grenade launcher
with two grenades in them I think I got
a board here and I can get another one
I'm pretty sure I left one remember when
they said that there were liquors and I
got panicked and I didn't grab boards
they're still boards there somewhere
yeah
did I use all of the key I had I guess I
did
yeah I'm trying member so you got the
red book you could go put that where it
belongs I guess actually yeah you might
as well do that before you forget it's
kind of right off the main hall anyway
okay should I keep this or should I take
put this away
keep the grenade launcher it's you use
it far more early on in this game and
then you might think interesting what
about this cutting tool yeah you still
need it yeah but while you're at it take
those other two flame rounds because
it's not gonna take up any more
inventory space she's gonna stack right
smart the knives I it's brand new it's
shiny yeah it's so functional I don't
think I need all this stuff then you'll
get rid of the book fast quickly and
probably the board as well so let me
just check the map then so where does
the book go second floor East Side in
the art room got it is this guy still
shot
Oh Marvin oh he does not look good no
he's dead I think now he's moving now
he's new he's about to be Undead
let me timing is no bearing on this
right like that's just game and it
depends on like what you accomplish when
you're away from the main hall I would
assume because I've been in this menu
for ages oh yeah no it's like all
dependent on what you do yes then you're
the end of the hallway on the left
mm-hmm we're the same left are there
zombies in here I don't think so
so it's through that door and then like
so they're just safe back there right
but I don't have the combo correct
are there zombies in here I think this
is where the guys that were on fire were
but it's in that room this room yeah the
air true oh man I do not like this
you've been in here before
hey no put the book in his hand okay
SiC hey my first puzzle thing I got a
Royal scepter sorry I mean at least
you're not in the room with me can't get
any of these germs yeah I'm already kind
of getting sick anyway I inspect that
when you get the chance okay it's that
time of year you know inspect things Oh
pricey yeah you could probably just go
put that back in your item box now try
to remember what Wow so green next thing
you want to do is I could have done that
last episode I need a crank to get in
there oh yeah
there were some zombies that I didn't
kill because I got overwhelmed remember
that there was like three in a row and I
couldn't kill all of them yeah you got
the grenade launcher okay all right so
now do me a favor and open up your map
you got it buddy bet you never thought
you hear me say that okay can we zoom
out
no there's stuff in the East office yes
go up go up stairs on the map there's
the dark room safety deposit room and
get everything in and there's stairs I
guess
oh yeah the operations room with a
chained door oh I have a thingy to cut
that chick where's this a chain door
this is it right here
Oh gotcha cool yeah might as well locked
door okay so we're going to the chained
door mm-hmm all right how should I go
through reception I guess yeah it's just
right to the left of the main hall it's
also yeah what I don't I'll explain
after it's not like anything pressing
it's just it's like a a scenario B
scenario kind of thing
people like when I push you through the
floor in the library that was [ __ ]
rude actually like the meanest way to
begin this the second episode yeah
you're just going all the way around yo
you could board up one of these windows
actually I don't know if you'll be
coming back here that much
so I already open this or no I don't
have a key so I need to go up through
here and then take a left no no I can't
do that
actually yeah I guess I think you got no
no that's not a door not a door remember
that's where you jumped over
from the kraits that that's like that
vent thing in the ceiling you got to go
the long way around I mean you could but
I don't think you're gonna be coming
through here that often anymore okay
I'd rather not waste them I boarded up
this one but no you didn't board up that
first one I think that was just already
boarded up to to demonstrate how boards
could be helpful yeah just go okay I'm
lost
oh my god shut up they're yelling turn
right and then go through the door okay
should I get it
I can't I can't I can't I can't I can't
okay
I would heal I feel really stressed out
um okay sharp yeah I would kill them
it's worth getting the knife really
there's a lot of that do you know that
you know I have to use a grenade no you
don't use a grenade I have seven bullets
do you know no whoa do you really
wait wait wait go back to your inventory
r1 now you have 14 all right you got it
there's too many Highschool critical
place
there's too many oh my god fine there's
no knife in the world worth this okay go
okay all right now discuss through the
rope
I'm [ __ ] dying yes all right okay
it's Jen door and now you can get rid of
the bolt cutters there was nothing worth
that knife isn't worth what just
happened to me you will say that again
when you're at read health and someone
grabs you oh my god
it's okay check out aha
what is that what is that
maybe a liqueur you know I don't have
any ability to survive this scenario hey
you got grenade launcher umm look at the
marker board yeah oh it's an herb
oh they're trying to get in that door
can they do it
yeah [ __ ] great should I eat this no
it's alright hit those boards again
should I kill this person um no I would
just go through that door to your left
if you can if there's all [ __ ] that
might be locked you might have to kill
that first oh do I have to yeah yeah
down and ex I believe [ __ ] ex I'm not
sure down circle I'm gonna die it's
actually probably good to reconnect last
part
okay that's actually good in the long
run that's the first time I've ever died
ever we know that's not true
Oh in this game in this game and in my
life yeah um listen yeah you could
probably just sprint through that
hallway next time when they're coming in
too you know I feel silly I didn't save
after the Ruby so I have to do that part
again you don't have I mean yeah you
know autosave sweet um actually that's
not good do you know Jimmy the load cuz
I could load yeah you do
that's one yeah I do that's one of the
minor actually minor critiques of the
autosave is really arbitrary is it here
mhm
no no no I'm go down I think it's five
yeah oh my god how sneaky is that it's
Auto and then it goes one two five okay
yes we thank God you looked holy cow
that would have restarted the game you
could do the jewel laughter let's do
this part and then we'll go do the jewel
later cuz the jewel is gonna be there so
we're like the jewel doesn't go away
it's act it's the it's not for something
that it's you won't need it until way
later in the game okay
well then I will do the hallway again
and better here's a question I'm
definitely gonna have to attack some of
those people right like I probably can't
Juke everybody in the world actually
think I have everything I need
yeah take just take those extra two
grenades just in case oh right thank you
and I don't even I wouldn't even bring
those boards because there were boards
in that last room you were in so you're
gonna have them anyway that's why you're
you mm-hmm I'm a smart boy tell me I'm
smart you're smart talk about genius hmm
okay let's do it we meet again old
friend hallway oh my god I hate this all
right go go go go
oh my god got you okay [ __ ] that I know
you'll get the flashbang you get does
the same thing go great great wait are
you kidding like are you kidding they
should rub you down I can't
well [ __ ] am I you gotta write words
um how about backwards yeah okay go for
their legs maybe okay you might as well
grenade them there's five of them I know
how much what I have no idea
oh [ __ ] what fact that one girl two of
them made it through Oh burn burn you
[ __ ] no don't don't waste ammo yet I
don't know if yeah you might want
this is the worst game of my life there
- they're too close
I'm sorry this hallways really hard okay
I I have a new plan
there's no no there's handgun ammo in
the East office that you can use and a
flashbang grenade and yeah in a
flashbang so that you can use the
flashbang is also a defensive item so
you can really bolster up cuz that's
there's like five or six on he's in the
hallway should I should I board up the
window I was thinking that I don't know
if you can get there in time before he
jumps through [ __ ] that was so hard well
take those boards now if you're gonna
try that am i it could work I don't know
it looked like he was he would have
jumped through so yeah go to the office
this time the through that shutter door
- yeah no no no it's just right through
here you're right sorry not you're right
yeah there's handgun ammo in here there
might be a dude up around the corner
obviously you can't remember yes through
this door to the right I came over if
you killed all the guys in here or not
yeah I guess so
oh you could cheat a little bit I hear
somebody so you could this looks
important
yeah it's a valve humor oh no I don't
remember it that would be for come on
your grenades what my grenades do you
remember what the valve is for well
upstairs yeah with the steam and you
said you need a valve yeah um so I
actually can't take the flashbang now
yeah that will help
I think they're near that dead dude
behind you
o out this window should I board the
window not not not out it yeah
no no no look they're near that dead
dudes body like they're over there huh
yeah they got to go up to him no first
of all I'm full you know I'm full
I know but handgun rounds aren't gonna
take up any more space like a look at
your map there there on there flashbangs
like to your left dish but there's
handgun rounds on him I don't know I'm
trying to think if you can use any so
that's that will help in the hallway
okay we could cheat a little bit so we
saw the code to the dial walk up stairs
it was not cheating you died you died
for the code it was like remember it was
like cat or something close wait wait
wait wait horn put something else
there's a green herb in there as well in
my person no in that room so I put
something else in the storage thing for
now the Gunpowder right no I'll bring
the board's okay man I can't believe I
died twice already
hallway sucks dude this is the last I
think that's a little disentitle to go
back that way there's a guy you don't
say okay so you know that the flashbang
can also be used like a knife like a
reactionary defensive weapon that one
now I do what should I do about this
scenario here you can just back out of
it you can just go out the room you can
easily dodge it play cat and mouse
around the desks okay
and he's not gonna follow you into the
main hall anyway so oh they did a really
good job with like just making them
sound gross okay
so I've gotten some items I feel good
about that
you can save now if you want I probably
will considering what's been happening
where am I going now the hallway yeah
okay I basically spent like 20% of this
episode dead we've made progress we know
the code to that dial lock up on the in
the locker room all right so I'm gonna
board up this window if you can get
there in time otherwise like if you're
getting toured and you feel like you
can't just keep moving this one right
yeah try oh nope nope nope just keep
going
oh she's gonna be around the corner
though yeah okay cut that be able to
drop the bolt cutters okay so wait hon
you know I need you what you don't ya
sorry
yeah he'll but when you go into this
next room just gather everything really
quickly so you don't have to like fight
zombies off and waste ammo if they come
in after you okay
are there zombies in here no but
remember the last time they came through
the door yes
if you get everything in here quickly
enough you won't have to fight them
because there's a door I'm out like
there's the door right there to get out
okay oh wait check it the no no don't
pick that up you need the electronic
thing won't it come bin maybe yes okay
good where's the electronic right not
combine I don't think you could try go
pick go see if get that thing damn it
okay sorry
I trying so hard okay
welcome back what door am I going
through the one right to my left
ah no far to your left this one yeah now
you should be safe now now just take a
right to get back to the main hall
that's right okay what's okay a West
office and then main oh oh no actually
no no you could go to the darkroom save
box and because you're going upstairs
anyway to do the valve thing okay so go
take a right
yeah and you boarded up this window a
long time ago so you're set I did yes
it's a straight hallway there's no other
way to go there you go shoot me to go to
the dark room or upstairs yeah yeah well
I mean your inventories full yeah you're
right you're right oh my god that
actually for tempo so scary I did okay
so like I lost tonight no no no you lost
health which is fine right
that knife will is in my opinion more
useful than yeah yeah you're fine that
worked out well okay so what would you
like me to get rid of I have an extra
herb but I'd have no other health
besides oh you wait hold on back out you
can just completely discard the
bolt-cutters for the record yeah like
resonable zero okay the series has
digressed no it's good you don't need
that electronic thing right now
ah no if you have a knife I'd say store
the flashbangs for the time being okay
uh okay maybe open your map I'm trying
to think of what Windows you're gonna be
able to possibly board up if you go up
here so you're going up yep I press up
on the d-pad so yeah the valve is right
there
to the left of the stairs that's where
the shower linen room Stars office if
you're on the second floor I don't even
think you can board most of those
windows so I just store the boards and
the flashbangs I don't think you'll need
those those of the knife and there's a
lot of stuff in the Stars office I think
saving again I don't care yeah that's
fine you got a lot done I'd save to no
fear oh wait [ __ ] sorry do you take the
valve I didn't know I forgot the police
department's got a darkroom
whatever happened to their bright room
alright so going upstairs X yes so you
completely avoid its spoilers for the
game right yes you have thus are is it
here no no it's right it's we're up here
no no no not up just like down the
hallway to the right and yeah right
there in in the door through the door
okay sorry
through the bathroom yeah number that's
where the steam is
oh right also you know the code some
dialog now to know that dude scared you
a lot yay fell out of the [ __ ] locker
what was it a CAD cap app yeah that
makes so much sense
give me something good no puzzles no
puzzles no puzzles nobody taking my
grenades yeah what a weird thing to keep
in a locker once that pipe gonna give us
half-life 3
sweet what happened here
I'm a little little freaked out no good
ever happens in bathrooms at least
they're all empty no reflection that
dude is so alive
I don't know that did it I can make me
go well waste a bullet more lockers be
careful
gunpowder nothing what a bunch of
[ __ ]
okay
I hate this
oh my god I died so horribly yeah kicked
up against the wall ooh
I'm like having a heart attack here your
own worst enemy to you I'm freaking out
this guy knows I'm talking about
Oh his butt is bloody dude I know I told
you this guy had the worst death ever
broken neck gone foot gone arm bloody
but bloody but that guy's alive I don't
know that range should have woken him up
that looks really good by the way the
rain like the mist coming in yeah so I
should go into the stars office hmm I
would say so
yeah it does look good
oh go go into Stars office
that's a liqueur grenade launcher in
case he comes in I just got [ __ ] up
first of all what was it I'm literate I
didn't see it cuz I was looking at that
guy on the floor here it must have been
on a ceiling or something either way
[ __ ] um cool there's a lot of stuff in
here
I can't believe that happened
thanks enter welcome you're welcome
Center so I need a like a disk okay you
can kind of see what's in there hmm
that's like an Uzi yep flashbang
maybe that's Chris's desk golden
retriever
don't stop retriever
oh it's Rebecca chambers uh we played at
her it's her health bag first-aid kit
she was a member of stars I'm full what
should I do
are you I thought you had one more then
the last thing is a red herb anyway so
you can just combine it I probably would
it's right near the door it's your left
there's also an office right there yeah
[ __ ] you need that too in Oh actually
you could combine those two gunpowder's
I'm trying to member what those two
would give you grenades I think let's
find out mellow yellows
that's what Barry called him AHA safe
combo hey that's my birthday well I was
seven on that day
left nine right 15 left seven I need to
write that down I got it you do mentally
I play this game three times and it's
the same code every time so I remembered
it so that's in the West
her name was Isabel so is the liquor
outside yeah so hold on let's figure
this out okay um open your inventory
okay so you're full you need the battery
on aesthetic an you go to the red door
to the lounge it's locked I don't know
if that's like a heart door or I don't
even know no no no no so that that that
unlocks from this side so you're set
because remember that's where I'm see
you've gone into the lounge before but
this is the yeah you can get through
that door but you also might be able to
linen room either way I would just kill
this no actually okay so liquors if you
walk slowly they won't hear you but if
you touch them they will so you could be
quiet and just walk even out the door
yeah but have your grenade launcher
ready just in case I don't like this oh
I love it it's gonna be great I'm on
caution Oh does it take to it it's it's
it's either one or two it's kind of
random okay so you're gonna go out and
then go left but quietly if you think
he's gonna like I'll yell abort if I
think it's gonna go wrong did you hear
good you could just yell if you want
that's completely first of all it's not
like I can just kill him
yeah but the grenades will knock him
back
where is he left or right I have no clue
I would I would imagine right because
that's where he was
this is hell oh is he on the ceiling
don't don't worry don't worry - keep
going look to your left
he's on the wall the wall to your left
no I'm not don't sprint don't panic
okay Gabe you might want to shoot him
shoot him now run it whoa [ __ ] okay I
only took one did you see him on the
wall when you turned around no oh my god
that was you pand your flashlight - look
behind you and I saw his face on the
wall like thank God the game can't hear
me because if I was not allowed to
scream right then I would have died okay
try to open that just say it's marked as
a diamond door on your map okay sweet so
this is a pretty good shortcut to the
library oh my [ __ ] heart I worked out
and I took one grenade I didn't know
there flamer needs to be so uh you've
gotten this one right yeah that's the
first one it doesn't even let me touch
it
oh there's gunpowder over here oh
nevermind you can get us some other time
alright now what what do you have now
you have the battery I'm gonna I think
the library has bad guys in it yeah they
were like a bunch
oh you have the safe combo and the what
yeah let's just go back to the main hall
alright well then I go through the
library
yeah I wouldn't bother killing anybody
if you can avoid it she'll be pretty
easy to dodge around the tables oh I
forgot you killed like six alright good
I just scared myself I did I did kill a
lot alright so I'm back in the main hall
I'm saving like the coward that I am but
extrication
get rid of some stuff right I've got to
write down some stuff just so I remember
later like gunpowder in the linen room I
mean do I need the battery now that's a
good question I don't want to give it
away yeah but you also okay so i'll get
rid of the acid rounds I don't need
those right now
honey what I would give her the
flashbang as well okay so yeah you need
the battery you need to combine it with
that electronic device that's what's
gonna detonate the seafloor upstairs
remember you the c4 you came across but
it only had the gel it didn't have the
actual detonator yes that's your next
big thing you can combine to put the
battery in that and then that'll take up
one space okay but you also have a safe
combo in the West office there yeah I
would bring some boards cuz you'll be
going up and uh yeah that's good I have
I'm already on yellow should I take a
green herb and just smash it yeah might
as well
I'll give a [ __ ]
I'm gonna save as often as I my heart
feels alright your success with the
liquor made up for that first hallway
thank you
so detonate or I'd say go to the safe in
the West office first you have the
combination now where Oh
in the West office mm-hmm there's guy
there's guy in here I think that's the
East yeah you're right is there a guy in
the West what's in here this might be a
weapon upgrade I don't know there's a
bunch in this game I think you got
everybody in here we're just suspicious
of that light I don't trust nothing I'm
like beyond paranoid I'm like what her
jacket though oh you mean like just the
way it looks or the style the style
welcome cool it was it in the I think
you yeah what this is I think it's a
weapon okay all right left until you get
hit nine now the other direction till
you hit no you [ __ ] it up back out I
thought safes worked when you went past
the number that's the second number but
not in this game
no that's left nine now other way 15
slowed down oh my god how other way
seven
there you go axe what is it weapon up oh
hell yeah edge yeah
[Music]
I think we could there's a there's a
window nearby that would be help no
that's the east side Oh buddy wrap quick
oh yeah okay so now you want the
detonator and you got to go back up to
kind of through the library and up to
the room near there
upstairs yeah do wait do you have the
detonator yes yes okay yeah so back into
the main hall and then upstairs and
through the library
wait is that right hold on
no I think you're on the east side I'm
trying right where this open the map one
more time sorry also I love that you
actually her belt gets bigger like on
yeah every every physical piece of her
seems a good dead space like headless
thing okay um you are going to the go to
the right side no it's on the east side
I was wrong so into the waiting room is
it here no go down a floor press down
hmm the watchman's room maybe it is a
doodle library but what's through there
no that's the West it's no it's
definitely the east side it's it's the
c4 room in that like for how it is
called maybe it was the private
collection room upstairs yeah maybe just
going to the rune oh oh that's it it's
the West storage room yes so it's the
sorry yeah it's a third floor so you're
going through the library I was right
the first time
okay [ __ ] you just want to go the third
floor in general you don't even have to
go through the library go down one more
floor one more time okay you can go
through the West office and then you're
gonna go to the dark room like not the
dark room but those stairs and then just
all the way up those stairs to the third
floor and then you're pretty much there
okay so down to the right in the West
office upstairs yes
[ __ ] okay hold on I'm what yeah yeah I
was right the first time
I forgot the library doesn't give you
access to that hallway that we need to
go to I'm overthinking it
you're getting in my head with your
paranoia no I'm not you're just dumb top
left to me okay right yeah I will be the
one who decides left or right with the
map thank you very much
fine now I come in on the east side I'm
[ __ ] so paranoid right now so I'm
going on my stairs right all the way up
those stairs and go up two floors don't
need your map what up loser SAP losers
[Laughter]
sweet we are sort of here it's just like
down this hallway this hallway is
ominous I remember this hallway yeah
bunch of jerks
I got scared by my own shadow
I should have saved that's alright
you'll be fine
oh [ __ ] have your grenade launcher out
though are you [ __ ] kidding me yeah
sorry
you'll see telegraphic line equip your
grenade launcher yeah yes you're going
in there getting those yeah you can get
those bored they'll stack in the West
storage room yeah but see the the
exclamation point the south end of the
West our room that's where you plant the
c-4
[Music]
you hate this room don't you
nothing's even happy I hate a lot like I
hate dogs I hate this room hey children
I hate children
I hate liquors I hate like what is that
like what the [ __ ] is that
hey I don't know and if a station of the
g-virus something stack them all right
now you're bussing those dead dudes out
of jail what I was kidding
I believe the last medallion is oh where
am I going to that exclamation point
south side it's the worst
I'm gonna I think you can walk more
quickly right now you can yeah I don't
even breathe when I play this game and I
haven't even gone to like the real [ __ ]
yet I'm sure of it that's not run away
do I can I die
ah where should I go just around the
corner I guess so it doesn't kill you
you're probably fine right here
do you kill these men definitely gonna
attract something go in there quick
no there's nothing in there I think it's
just attracting things from out
elsewhere hey it's the last medalie yeah
you know yes it is
wait is it yeah
I don't know that is he still around
while I'm doing this
yeah you got to check your notebook
anyway but he's like hanging out while
I'm flipping dials I guess so
it's like straight up supposed to pause
goddess statue all right woman bow and
arrow and snake your are that's a woman
that's a bow and arrow I think that's
this name sweet cool now let's like [ __ ]
off weird to go back to the main hall
you have the third medallion but no I
mean like right now
Oh probably quickest to the library so
take this right at the blue door to the
right correct if it's a liquor honestly
just say [ __ ] it up with your grenade
launcher like I mean you could cat and
mouse it around that like oh it's just a
regular [ __ ] him
okay so okay
The Doors blocked by a bookshelf no just
I would say just kill that liquor I'm
not saying this to be a dick did you hit
the liquor or no I don't know I don't
think so I would I would yeah I would
just dodge and reload and kill him dodge
well I mean just I would reload and kill
the liquor I hear him
let's talk about this oh this is battery
the hallway
what do you mean to kill him am I gonna
come back here
no I guess not but I don't hold on oh
wait open your rabble I guess not
yeah you could just go the really long
way like down the stairs I'm just saying
you're right I would just go downstairs
you're not you're not gonna need to come
back up here except for that the locker
out here how far does he follow me I
think you're fine now oh my god that
like zombie trick yeah it's very good
it's too good what up loser is he did he
come out no they can't the board just
stop all right just do that through that
door straight ahead
that's one no left left left left left
yes yes now left oh right oh my god I
thought that was a zombie I think
everything is the zambian it's a zombie
in the shape of a Pixar logo I mean when
you see it like even this post the
shadow looks like a dude
like I see dudes everywhere absolute
hell is Martin dead yet that's a spoiler
well he's gonna die no he's fine he's
he's doing great
I hope he'll make it should I do this or
should I save first yeah
sweet no say you could save and it's
actually probably perfect end to that
episode because you're going down there
next time
ain't nothing good in there do you
remember in re 7 the first time you get
access to go to the basement you're just
like [ __ ] you nobody wants to go in that
basement don't make it like a like a
feature it's like now you can check out
the basement
yeah this chair at the top
yeah awesome alright sweet you got a lot
done I wrote some things down like for
the gunpowder and red jeweled and stuff
right gunpowder and linen room red jewel
and art room Tommy Wiseau in the room
I'm just gonna turn off this intro real
fast the intro automatically plays I
need to stop that okay I'm gonna
duplicate the scene before I forget and
make it good bye Mikey poopoo
that's your name don't wear it out well
I asked what you wanted your name to be
and I think you said poop
poopy boy sorry I wouldn't blame me for
that next episode the descent hey you
can see the whole screen right it looks
like I'm like it looks like I'm like
looking down on you it looks like I'm
judging you see and then Mike yeah sweet
we'll have fun in San Francisco or
wherever you're going oh well and I hope
you guys have a really good weekend
and continue to enjoy this series with
us the polar vortex is here what's that
it's just a big snowstorm coming to New
York it's gonna be great I'm gonna play
a lot of I don't even know if I'm
allowed to say what game I got it's a
game coming out soon
oh hey what's today it's
Saturday I'll be I'm gonna be playing
much I'll probably have beaten Metro
Exodus by the time this airs nice
outside of that probably playing my last
campaign of resonable - I have I still
have Leon B scenario to do I'm enjoying
it a lot I like the game of this game
yeah scary as hell I like don't
understand why it's so much scarier when
they yeah when they add all these like
little facets you know it's just like I
just never feel relaxed and they do
those sneaky things right like they're
doing a lot of misdirection in this one
where I'm constantly thinking I'm okay
and I'm not and every time that happens
my heart is just like dead it's going to
get worse I guarantee you I know I I've
been avoiding spoilers but I know people
have been like talking about like some
giant man or some big thing I'm not sure
what it is but it sounds awful no
comment
it sounds not good do you yeah I'm not
saying anything you'll see soon enough
ish maybe not next episode but after
that next episode has its own frights
but okay Jerry trip thank you thanks
everybody for joining us if you have fan
art like Jimmy circus or a friend David
Hart or the one that's in the back right
now from correct me if I'm wrong say GE
87 yeah they're in the Knievel discord I
saw a few more people join the discord
in the last like week or so they have a
general chat they have a fan art chat
they have they're all sharing each
other's like gameplay from this game so
it's a really cool community I check in
like once a weekend I try to after an
episode goes up Mary does as well but
thank everybody for joining us we'll be
around in GameSpot next week
most likely Saturday at 3 p.m. Pacific
as always and we'll see you then bye
[Music]
bye-bye no way oh right I got stuff
recording it's always these ruin you did
these